starting pitcher for the diamondbacks
tonight wearing the sedona right on this
wednesday evening the right-hander zach
galin who just turned 26 years old
yesterday so happy belated birthday
looking for just his second win this
year and his first since that shutout in
atlanta back on april 25th and gallon
delivers and posey strikes out swinging
he went with the slider off the plate
posey chased it galla's got his first
strikeout that's not number two here on
this opening i think and he swings and
he skies it to right for calhoun
should be easy colt comes in under it
and he has it and that'll end the inning
no runs a walk-a-man left
all-star this year for the first time in
his career nine wins a 2-3-5 era that's
fourth best in the national league but
he has struggled lately kevin gausman's
two and two pitch splinters struck him
out swinging strong inning for gosman
one two three inning with a strikeout
for kevin gossman two up two down and
that'll bring up duggar the center
fielder one-two pitch to duggar and a
swinging strike three gallon strikes out
his second and the side in order for san
francisco
one out here's varshall giants had the
over shift out for him now nobody at
third base oh two pitch
swing gonna miss another fast ball he
blew it right by him
so two down and here comes ahmed the 01
pitch
and a slider is a looping liner to
second base backing up into the outfield
solano makes the catch
inning over that was a hanger but hit
off the end of the back
for this year's got got success he's a
left-handed batter six for 33 and the
pitch to him is strike three called
came in with a breaking ball on owen two
and he froze gosmen and gossman becomes
the third strikeout victim of the night
four zach galland won out
and finally gets tired of it and just
fires a fastball in there strikeout
number four for zach he takes off 3-2 is
hit on the ground and past the dive of
hager
estrada moving with the pitch easily
over to third tommy la stella's on base
for the second time that's the first hit
of the game giants have first and third
two down and a ground ball hit sharply
diving play ahmed the throw to first and
he got him nick ahmed took a hit and a
run away from the giants with a diving
stop it's short to get posey to end the
giant threat jake hager recently
acquired off waivers from seattle its
second start
and he has a base hit to center field
right over salado's head who is playing
him up the middle of the second baseman
and hager's on with the lead off single
to start third inning first diamondback
pacer on their first time back yet baker
staying put got him swinging with the 96
mile an hour fastball that's that's the
swing and miss that sends big league
hitters back to the bench talking
themselves
here's the 1-0 pitch
swing and there's a high
pop fly shallow right center coming in
from right field is estrada but under it
is solano and the solano makes the grab
inning over now stellano banter the base
is empty he lined the right field his
first time up three and two having a
battle here gallon to the plate and that
one is hit to left field and well hit
going back on it var show all the way to
the wall it is gone
donovan solano goes deep the giants are
on the board one nothing
johnny barrels finds another barrel his
fifth home run of the year and the all
one pitch and a broken background ball
to second hager's got it he'll throw
onto caprero and that'll in the end one
out two late a home run by salado on the
3-2 pitch is giving the giants the lead
two outs for drew ellis to start tonight
at third base one-two pitch is swung on
it missed strike three splitter got him
that's the fourth strikeout in four
innings for kevin gausman ellis is
retired the d-backs go down
someone out gossman struck out his first
time up he was up trying to bunt the
runner over failed to do so
didn't check on the curve strikeout
number five for zach uh he's out on
strikes and that's odd number two and
for gallon that's strikeout number five
and the pitch and he struck him out
swinging
on the breaking ball and the side
retired two strikeouts in the inning
four gallons six in the ball game it's
the bottom of the fifth in phoenix
giants lead one nothing
swung on and missed strike three man
fastball got him and varsho
marshall does not look very comfortable
against kevin gausman strikes out
swinging for the second time
and a fly ball hits a deep center going
back as duggar looks up it's off the
wall
and ahmed's into second base standing
with a one out double a nick hammered
that ball duggar couldn't get back there
in time played it off the wall two and
two
gaussman throws and he struck him out
swinging with the splitter two down
great pitch again from gausman two outs
two outs runner at second the o2 is a
fastball struck him out swinging 96
miles an hour
and gosman strikes out the side a hit a
man left diabetics have left two gospels
fans seven through five it's one nothing
giants here's the pitch lestella hits a
hard ground ball into right field base
it tommy the stella's got another hit
he's two for two and on base for the
third straight time crawford's going to
be the hitter with runners at first and
second and one out there allen to
crawford and a line drive to left and it
stays up caught back to second and safe
there marshall made the catch and fired
to second base perfectly
but uh stella got back in that sound
number two on the inning and now a hit
here by solano could play the couple one
two here's the pitch it is hit to right
field base hit donovan solano
la stella in to score here comes
dickerson around third the throw and it
skips by holiday three-nothing giants
gold cowhoon the batter now goes fly to
center he's flying to right
there's a base hit
all kinds of room over there for calhoun
good start to the six
and nobody out down three nothing a
chance for cattell martay
he has lined out to left and grounded to
first he's over two i think she was just
putting on the two-finger hex good
folder hat
guess the barbara bernard stank guy
going
and there's the two-finger hex
okay here we go
mark j waiting the pitch is bounced up
the middle crawford has it he's going to
run to second step on the bag there then
throw the third behind peralta who stays
on the bag that's all the giants could
get one out for cabrera who has struck
out and fly to center he is a tied run
to the plate and the pitch to cabrera
and the live drive base hit to right a
run is in marte will stop at second it's
a three to one ball game on the rbi
singled by as druba cabrera as he
continues his hot hitting
here's the pitch it is a splitter and
that one is a broken bad bloop out to
short caught by crawford two down
struck him out for the third straight
time
guzman that's number eight on the
evening
tonight has gone over three he batched
with two on and two out
fastball there's a shot to left field
and that's gonna sail up over the head
of varshall one hop up against the wall
then marshall plays the camera and drops
it slater had already stopped coming
around third it's four to one giants
that one is smoke to right field on its
way and it is gone
a three-run homer
for alex dickerson and this has turned
into a four-run rally
seven-to-one giant and now chris bryant
will come up as a pinch-hitter
buckowskis throws there's a swing and a
line drive base hit
just past
the dive of drew ellis the third baseman
hard hit single to left by chris bryant
for the giants eighth hit of the game
there's a swing of the miss
and down on strikes swinging his way for
the fourth time tonight and the inning
is over so one hit they get by brian as
a pitch hitter good pitcher now for the
giants jose alvarez game number 39 4-1
with a 2-7-5 era 2-2 pitch
fastball driven to right field coming on
and reaching down to make a thigh high
catch austin slater
and the ball game is over